[Music]
union
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
fabulous
[Music]
[Music]
realisable
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
for a castle straight out of a fairy
tale look no further than the alcazar of
segovia
[Music]
located in central spain the alcazar of
segovia is one of the country's most
visited and distinctive landmarks
built in the 12th century the alcazar
has served many functions over the years
a fortress a royal palace a state prison
an artillery college and most recently a
museum and military archive
however its most famous function could
arguably be that it served as an
inspiration in some of the most iconic
disney films
the similarities between sergovia and
cinderella can be found in the
building's brick facade turrets and
location perched high above the
neighboring countryside
walt disney also went on to reproduce
segovia as the queen's castle and snow
white with it appearing in the film in
its almost exact form
if you can make it up more than 150
stairs to the top of the tower you will
be rewarded with stunning views fit for
a queen
[Music]
once a hub of french aristocratic
parties this castle in the countryside
lies abandoned after falling victim to a
house fire
[Music]
a few hours outside paris are the
remains of the chateau de lemont chander
nien
the castle was built in the 14th century
and was owned by french nobles
it was conquered twice by the british in
the middle ages and was devastated
during the french revolution
around 60 years later after a wealthy
relative of napoleon iii took control he
restored the castle to its former glory
however in 1932 just after central
heating was installed a violent fire
broke out
since the fire the castle has been
slowly taken over by nature trees have
grown through the interior and vines
crawl along the once sturdy castle walls
though its fate is still uncertain today
there are efforts to save the castle
with the group raising money to restore
the ruins
[Music]
located in yemen is a palace that
appears to have been carved from the
rock that it sits on
however this man-made wonder was once
just a simple summer home
[Music]
just 10 miles away from yemen's capital
city of sanaa is da al hajjah otherwise
known as iman's rock palace
[Music]
in the early days of yemen's history the
country was led by the imam the islamic
spiritual leader rather than a king or
president
the rock palace was built in the 1930s
by imam yahar as his summer residence
however it is believed to have been
built over an older palace
the residence is five stories high has
several balconies and its own water
supply from a deep well
it is seen as an example of traditional
yemen architecture due to the patterned
windows earth tone coloring and
protruding exterior decorations
while tourism in this region is limited
due to conflict this palace is both a
sanctuary for locals and an example of
the man-made beauty of yemen
[Music]
located in postonia slovenia is a sturdy
castle built into a natural cavern
halfway up a 400-foot cliffside
[Music]
pradyama castle was built in the 13th
century in gothic-styled architecture
however after a siege in the 16th
century the exterior was reconstructed
and is what you see today
but there's more to this castle than
meets the eye
beneath it lays the postonia cave park
the caves are accessible during may to
september and closed in the winter so as
not to disturb the hibernating local
bats
the castle has changed ownership
throughout its history however the most
famous inhabitant was ezrim luga he was
a 15th century robin hood-like character
who stole from the rich to give to the
needy
today the castle and caves are open for
the public to explore and learn more
about its previous colorful owners
with more than 65 000 square feet of
space and 115 rooms hearst castle is one
of america's largest and most treasured
homes
hearst castle was built by american
newspaper magnate william randolphurst
in 1919 after he inherited 40 000 acres
of farmland
he would go on to purchase 200 000 more
acres of land allowing him to create the
kind of sprawling compound rarely seen
to this day
in addition to the main house la casa
grande hearst castle is comprised of
three guest houses an outdoor pool and
numerous other amenities
one of the most recognizable rooms in
the hearst castle is the 345 000 gallon
indoor roman pool
styled after ancient roman baths the
pool is decorated with eight statues of
roman and greek gods goddesses and
heroes
hearst was known for throwing lavish
parties and hosting important figures at
his san simeon home
winston churchill charlie chaplin cary
grant greta garbo and calvin coolidge
were some of the hundreds of house
guests
the home was donated to the state of
california in 1958 and welcomes more
than 750 000 visitors every year
[Music]
hidden away in the tuscan hills of
northern italy this beautiful moorish
castle was built in 1605
but for more than two decades it's been
sitting empty
there are 365 rooms in the castello di
samatsano
one for every day of the year
the moroccan style palatial villa is a
labyrinth of exquisitely tiled rooms
each one intricately unique
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the castle was once a luxury hotel
restaurant and bar but closed its doors
in the early 1990s
it wasn't until 2013 that a local
non-profit committee was founded to help
raise awareness for the increasingly
decaying castle
they have no ownership of samatsano but
they helped to arrange and promote rare
public openings
[Music]
what you're seeing was built by one man
pebble by pebble
over 33 years
one morning mailman ferdinand chaval
stumbled across an interesting looking
stone on his delivery route
he picked it up
and from there an obsession began
using stones he collected on his walk
chaval worked each night without any
formal training to build what is now
called the palais ideal
the final structure is 85 feet long and
300 feet high
it mingles chinese algerian and northern
european influences to create a
fantastic and completely original castle
of grottoes
[Music]
he opened the palace in 1870 for the
public to enjoy
[Music]
in his own words he says
you start wondering if you have not been
carried away into a fantastic dream with
boundaries beyond the scope of
imagination
[Music]
and this incredible bizarre and unique
place
does look like something you could only
see in a dream
you